[Musique]
tout le monde se souvient de ce qu'il
faisait ce jour-là le jour de la
catastrophe
[Musique]
on était qu'avant km de l'explosion
la catastrophe a emporté des gens qu'on
aimait mais elle a laissé des traces de
leur passage les rémanents
sourit
nous ignorons encore beaucoup de choses
sur eux
il rejoue certains moments de leur vie
voire de leur mort mais en tout cas ils
ne peuvent ni communiquer avec vous ni
vous toucher il se passe quoi avec les
mecs zarbi le mec barbie girl elle est
obsédée par les rênes
j'étais observé en cours tu te pose plus
de questions que les autres des veillées
j'ai vu un nouveau rayman en aide moi je
dois découvrir qui sait qu'est ce qu'il
a ce type pourquoi il est intéressant je
crois qu'il veut me faire du mal
c'est un tueur meurt on laisse à mes
coups derrière nous
seiko peuvent devenir des passages dont
les morts peuvent se servir pour toucher
les vivants
c'était quoi ce tripolitain
j'ai bien peur que vous n'avez plus
beaucoup de temps
dans un monde où les morts air parmi les
vivants on ne peut pas se fier aux
apparences